look whether you like the guy or not
every time dr disrespect makes a move
the gaming world takes notice over the
past few months
he's gone from being banned on twitch
for mysterious and
still unknown reasons to resurrecting
himself on youtube
seemingly unscathed and now he's
designed
a new map and has his own character skin
in rogue company
a brand new multiplayer shooter looking
to make it big in the streaming world
that's something we've never seen a
major streamer do
so what the hell is up with doc
[Music]
alright so before i catch you up on the
goings-on of streaming's biggest super
villain
i've gotta remind you scroll down and
subscribe to our youtube channel
when you sub like our videos and comment
it really does help us a lot
and if you've got a tip for me and the
donate me team make sure to hit us up at
our email
tips at thescore.com okay so like many
of you since dr disrespect got
permanently banned on twitch at the end
of june
i've been sitting here for a while going
when the hell are we gonna find out what
happened
but in the meantime doc has been making
some moves
first he moved his daily streaming
duties over to youtube which of course
seemed like a natural fit given that he
already had an audience there
and well mixer is dead
[Music]
the announcement was cryptic retro and
well pretty cool which we've come to
expect from dog
anymore and since doc's been streaming
on youtube
somehow he may even be bigger than he
was when he was streaming on twitch
before being banned on twitch in june
doc was streaming to around
25 000 viewers concurrently every day
and since joining youtube
doc has been up closer to 35 to 40 000
viewers at a time on most days
now if you're not fully caught up on why
doc isn't streaming on twitch anymore
let me catch you up really quick all we
know as of now is that he's permanently
banned from the platform
his subs were refunded which is
extremely abnormal
and he appears to have lost a couple of
sponsorships in the process
and to this day there remains this
looming fear in the gaming world that
such a big punishment
would have had to be for something very
serious i i don't know exactly what
happened
and i'm not going to speculate about
what i think happened
i do get a sense of severity like the
the the whole
refunding and and uh and deleting his
emotes and stuff like that that that's
like
what kind of makes my makes gets me a
little bit worried
because i'm like oh man that this seems
like seems severe
oh and before he signed off his last
stream on twitch he seemed a little off
like nervous and uncomfortable i
appreciate everyone watching today
it's in the backyard who is going to be
a little bit bigger
we'll get through this champions club i
know it's a tough
life's weird right now i will get
through this okay
and all that makes it even more
impressive and from where i'm sitting
shocking that dr disrespect recently
announced a
huge partnership with a brand new game
called
rogue company
we're just getting started i'm at the
tippity top of the mountain
and i'm only halfway up
now this isn't your run-of-the-mill
partnership where a streamer gets like
a creator code and some cash to help
promote the game
not only does dr disrespect have his
very own skin
like of his face but he also designed an
entire [ __ ] map for this game this is
my video game in realm
this is my video game domain
ladies and gentlemen
damn it was only a matter of time
rogue company is a brand new 4v4 shooter
and they seem to be gunning pretty hard
for the streaming world
but by no means is this game a roaring
success yet
we're not talking like among us level
popularity or apex legends back when it
first released in 2019.
in fact as far as i'm concerned this
game seems to be getting
dragged along by the fact that it seems
to be doc's baby which is
insane considering this dude was almost
cast into the ether
a few months ago when he was banned
rogue company's developer first watched
games
has certainly taken a risk getting this
guy dr disrespect who's kind of like
twitch's
super villain to basically lead the
marketing of their brand new game
but i've got to admit the skin and the
map they look
pretty sick in fact i don't think
anybody
would be paying attention to rogue
company as much as they are without
doctor disrespect
first watch even dropped its weekly game
update the other day
with a staff member dressed as dr
disrespect
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
this week in rogue company
with millions of you already piled into
the servers
there was only one way to keep this
amount of violence
speed and momentum going and to me all
this says a lot about where the gaming
world is
at with doc everyone seems to be moving
on but all this
does beg the question what happens if we
find out that why he got banned
was something really bad do they just
delete the map out of their game
now as you might imagine doc's
affiliation with road company
hasn't landed without controversy one
thing you might not know is that a band
streamer cannot appear on twitch in
any way not on someone else's channel
not in voice comms you can't play doc's
clips
in this case you potentially can't play
with his skin
either and originally that put some of
his old friends on twitch
in an awkward position why would you
think his skin be a band
well that i would say it's only tricky
in that one part because it's literally
like
a hundred percent like his likeliness
you know
like it looks like him and everything
that would be the only that's why i said
it's a tricky
question right if it was like a gun skin
that's a little different
twitch also recently updated its
community guidelines on september 22nd
under the category suspension evasion to
make it crystal clear
that you can't have band streamers on
your stream
in addition it is prohibited to use your
channel to knowingly feature or
advertise a suspended user we understand
that there may be
instances where suspended users may
appear on your stream due to
circumstances beyond your control
such as through third-party gaming
tournaments but we expect that you make
a good faith
effort to remove them from your
broadcast mute them or otherwise limit
their interactions with your stream
end quote this change came just six days
after optic gaming founder hex
posted this video on his youtube channel
asking twitch to chill
when it came to doc appearing on twitch
partner streams
but right now there is a a thing going
around that if you stream
and you allow this voice this voice to
come through your microphone while
you're streaming on twitch you might get
banned
and hex's video is actually a reaction
to both nadeshot and crimsix
worried about being banned after doc
appeared on their stream in voice comms
during a war zone turn so needless to
say doc may be gone
but he's definitely more popular than
ever and he is still causing [ __ ] on
twitch
and this isn't a new conversation in
fact we've actually posited on this very
show before
that getting banned is actually good for
your popularity we just never knew
that that fact actually extended to
being permanently banned as well
he wants his return to be huge but i
think at the end of the day
it was always going to be huge and if
you're twitch
that's kind of a problem see this has
all happened before
literally it's happened to dr disrespect
before he came back to a
record-breaking stream with new theme
music composed by deadmau5 and over 388
000 concurrent viewers now not only have
these last few months been great for doc
but they've actually led to a huge boom
for youtube as well
we've spent a lot of time on donate me
talking about what i like to call the
great streaming wars
twitch has always been the top dog and
mixer
well they're dead now and youtube is
finally making the search
that some people namely me have
predicted the whole time
we've even seen valkyrie another content
creator with 100 thieves
who made the transition from twitch to
youtube become the most popular woman
streamer in the world
so what do you think is doc's post band
success a sign of more to come
or is this all gonna blow up in
everybody's face
when we finally figure out what he got
banned for
i need an end board board of the end
unfortunately i know that we're gonna
make an end board and then colton's just
gonna go
and find some like bloopers and somehow
make some like cinematic masterpiece out
of
as he usually does
yeah keith i gotta be honest i got
nothing